this is why we win this is why we are
ghosts Ghost Recon wildlands is the
latest in the tactical Tom Clancy series
and it sends the ghost to Bolivia to
battle the Santa Blanca cartel Ubisoft
has already shown off some of the game's
features including the different
environments and a ton of customization
options for your soldiers and thanks to
a new developer walkthrough we got to
see a full night mission in action
complete with a bunch of hot tips for
staying undetected here are the top five
things we learned number one watching
the weather no open world game is
complete without a day/night cycle and
time of day and weather can totally
change how you approach a mission so if
it's dark out and it's raining enemies
will have poor vision and hearing and
since your basic thugs don't carry
night-vision goggles cutting power to
the area will leave them completely
blind this could be a very wise move for
some of the game's harder missions
number 2 driving vehicles wildlands
features over 60 vehicles including
trucks and helicopters and bikes but
they can do more than just get you
around the map quickly if a vehicle
belongs to the Santa Blanca cartel like
say a delivery truck you can use it to
slip past checkpoints undetected it's
kind of funny if you think about it
since all the guys inside the truck are
still decked out in that custom military
gear we are ghosts number 3 using your
drone the ghosts have been carrying
drones sense future soldier but now we
know just what those little guys are
capable of in wildlands drones can mark
targets and use both night and thermal
vision to navigate the map with ease
they can also be upgraded with an EMP
blast that kills electronics a noise
generator that distracts enemies or
explosives if you need to go in guns
blazing and at some point you definitely
will number for hiding bodies night
missions are all about Stealth but even
in low light your enemies aren't blind
if they see the body of one of their
buddies they will alert the others so
hiding bodies is very important sort of
like in hitman dragging a fallen cartel
member into a
space is very important if you're trying
to stay low key number five helping the
rebels the ghosts maybe in Bolivia to
take on the Santa blanket cartel but
they're not alone there's also a rebel
faction that will fight with you if
given the chance so if you come across a
group of rebel prisoners freeing them is
a perfect example of help me help you
because they do not like the cartel in
their homeland Ghost Recon wildlands
deploys on ps4 xbox one and pc on march
seven 2017 you can expect plenty more
trailers and information to trickle out
in the meantime so keep an eye on
gamespot for all the latest